the Joe Rogan experience and then when
you go and watch our hulu series the
American saga right you get to see like
this group of men were always on the
same page wasn't always
there's no way trends with each other
and I think the biggest thing that I
learned by pitting the TV show on Hulu
is that there's other kids across
America in a similar situation yes right
so so there's a scene where it's the
soundtrack to life right but I just dare
talking about like there's a sign of
kids that are hearing this that they can
resonate does it make sense yeah so get
my first drum machine I have the you
know get it by illegal means right and
think about how many people think about
how many people you know leave something
to do something but don't have the means
to get it and some make foster learn you
know at the end of the day the way I
really got my equipment right you know
I'll definitely try to do anyway to get
it but I didn't get it by stealing it
right I had the hustle my so one is oh
you want it you didn't just want to get
it for say I got you one because you
wanted to do something with use it right
that's a difference I sold apples
oranges free newspapers socks I'm one of
those socks guys no no whatever cuz we
oh you bombed out 25th Street you get
maybe you'll get a dozen for 30 bucks
right and then you can sell them at $10
a pet so you get a dozen packs for 30
bucks with six in a pack you go uptown
right and you sell them for $10 just for
the whole package but you gotta find a
neighborhood at NIEHS socks you just get
going neighborhood it got a lot of sucks
but anybody you can't
but opposite is this use the uptown
right uptown usually people go uptown to
buy the clothes high-end clothes no no
you go home town to get no you get you
get drunk from uptown Oh drugs quite
like although I could get a whole
outlook for drugs uptown bring it back
downtown sell it for $200 yeah they had
the best race or any drill you ever
night but then why you buy drugs you
could buy a bounce uptown right and sell
it downtown or we even take it to back
to Staten Island you're gonna triple
your money
easy so satin islands 3ds like with your
money like the village is to here like
that okay if you go out of state you may
find and that's what all the New York
[ __ ] was coming down to DC and
Virginia but socks you buy downtown and
take it out town because the drug bill
is a flighty gonna have please it's so
dates without a buying the socks with
$10 that you pay you $5
[Applause]